Triumph the insult dog has uh insult
comic dog Howie insult comic dog hoe get
it wrong get it all right wa well so
anyway we are going to are we good are
we good are we focused all right Triumph
just shoot for average hoe be realistic
are we good is a little much thank you
thank you are we passible are we are we
tolerable that's what you shoot for
tolerable that's all that's all you need
Sals have already begun before the
beginning it's what I do it's what he
does I love this Triumph are you
thrilled to be here oh how we we go so
far back this is very exciting I
remember all those years you know I go I
was an 80s comic too I performed in the
sticks and then I got my shot on The
Tonight Show you know right and I killed
of course and afterward Johnny waved me
over and he pointed to the couch and he
said did you do this bad dog no you
ruined the couch and I said that's not
poop it's how
Mandel you dropped a cigar I get it you
know Tri actually those over there which
you nobody can see on camera is the
front row of The Tonight Show of Johnny
Carson's actual front row that's the
actual front row Burbank yes yes not how
old you how many how many uh chairs you
got there uh how many seats do you need
no no one for each wife of Johnny's it's
very nice I see what you did there very
nice right no we go way back Howe I'm so
proud I'm one of those people who gets
to proudly say that I knew you at the
very beginning and here I am at what is
clearly the end
a I I'm so old what I do I love it I'm
old yeah good because they get meaner
Howe good I I know expect you to be in a
great mood with Robert's fist up your
ass you should try it sometime okay I
how no we go right back I'm so old
ladies and gentlemen that I remember
when Howe had hair and the respect of
his
peers I don't remember that you're too
young you're too young Jaclyn the insult
daughter Jackie he's too young I by the
way you know uh back in the day how we
used to be famous people may know this
for putting a rubber glove on his head
yes I was in his comedy act I now he
only does it when he has to kiss his
wife P you see because he's a germaphobe
I get it I love the patum patum you know
well you know lowbudget it's a podcast I
can't afford an actual a rim shot actual
Rim shot P pum will do you don't always
put a rubber rubber glove on your head
pardon me that's why I was born get he
didn't put the rubber glove that's right
that's wrong head that's the one time
he's now just getting uncomfortable not
because of the insults he took by the
way Jackie he took a 5-Hour bath after
conceiving you yeah that's how freaked
out he
was it's nice to see your co-host Jackie
here Jackie I I would call you as a as
his daughter I'd call you a nepo baby if
this counted as being in show business
but un fortunately you're off the hook
thank you I K Howe you're still in show
he's you're still in Show theu he is and
I'm still in the French Bulldog that I
humped last night f f f seriously this
is honestly the lowest point in my
career since I was molested by Al in
the80s no it's I'm kidding he's more
than in showes hoe you still got that
AGT gig right I do that's right hoe it's
weird though you know that you're host
America's Got Talent since you're not
actually American or talented it's
amazing it's incredible
pum where's my cigar where the hell is
this whatever okay it doesn't
matter you you you you you have fun on
that show though I do I have a lot of
fun I enjoy I would like to be a judge
on that show really yeah I think the
producers would be too scared they I I
heard they said they would have to give
me a shot collar like the one they gave
melb
this show though now this show this
podcast wasn't affected by the actor's
strike right no it wasn't doesn't make
sense to me though because I think
you're an excellent actor hoe thank you
thank you like the way you act when
you're listening you blew the joke it's
okay do it again BW the joke you stupid
old Jew okay you I think you're an
excellent
hour actor oh boy get it together get it
together okay okay go ahead Howe I think
you're an excellent actor just like like
the way you act like you're listening
when Jackie
talks it's not an insult that's the
truth it's that's why it's funny because
it's
true now how are you have a you have a
very substantial acting career folks do
you know do you realize how he was the
voice of Gizmo in Gremlins right I
remember being on the set I don't for
interestingly though you didn't make a
sound when I uh [__] do the joke over
again how he was the voice of and grins
yes but uh interestingly Gizmo didn't
make a sound when I banged him let's
just say I did not follow thee don't get
them wet
rule is that okay to say a gross joke
because you're a germaphobe can I say a
joke that's disgusting like that yeah I
didn't touch it I didn't touch it didn't
touch the joke I didn't touch the joke
as long as you don't make my dad wet
he's okay oh good okay listen we all
know tring oh nice a trying oh my God
I'm getting [__] me trying now I'm
getting wet [__] me tring now I'm
getting wet stop trying I'm so wet Tri
[__] me oh yes oh yes but not after
midnight don't [__] me after
midnight I'm almost I'm almost
coming headphones truly gross this is
truly gross
no you know seriously though how is very
smart we all know he's a
germaphobe uh but thank God he's made
sure that nothing on his podcast will
ever go viral
fat and with that I Leave
You